the New York Times published Trump's
taxes from like 30 years ago you might
ask how did they get this stuff but that
doesn't matter if you hate the guy
besides publishing other people's stuff
is what The Times is all about
who cares if it was leaked or stolen or
may be borrowed from Trump it wasn't
always so easy about 13 years ago I was
seriously in trouble
I was billions of dollars in debt yep
that's what The Times reported last
night quite a bombshell also in The
Times last night the Berlin Wall down
the Bay City Rollers broke up nobody
knows them starwars actually a hit-and
Trump once lost a bundle say insiders
including Trump himself actually here's
an idea get the rich kid who owns the
Times to turn over his 10 40s so The
Times gets another Pulitzer they should
share it with Trump for tipping them off
years ago still the media of course
their response Pavlovian turns out
Donald Trump is our con man and chief
whatever the opposite of everything you
touch turning to gold is that is the
opposite of what Donald Trump had you
have a word for someone who can build up
an image like that despite the facts
correct con artists
no one has lost as much money right
maybe in a divorce anyway here's the
media's immortal take we got him again
this time right we got him right no but
it's fun to watch you try back tootle
arias they keep stepping on the same
rake and getting whacked in the head
again and again as all those anti Trump
headlines keep falling flats why is that
well life is good the economy is roaring
along unemployment keeps hitting record
lows so when you're in the media and the
world isn't going your way you got to
find another story even if that story's
been told over and over again by the
target himself so I can't wait to hear
about the next scoop that merit that
Trump's been married twice that he loves
golf
and women and yet what do you hear from
the American public it's the sound of
life in 2019 under Trump it's the sound
of calm but as the press should know by
now you can't hear it when you're
screaming
all right Dana I want to show you how
old this news is we have some pictures
here of some old a tabloid covers jilted
by Lady Luck that's about his financial
Ailes Trump slump again about his
financial Ailes that New York Times when
you can you can barely read is about his
financial Ailes and then of course
Donald dumps Marla which was a terrible
moment for me Danny you were about three
years old well I would say there's no
training for politics like having to go
through the New York media gauntlet
right and I didn't really appreciate
that
and until I've kind of been in politics
myself at the White House or even even
like here you work for Trump
I mean you work for Bush how it
absolutely can shape a whole generation
like everybody here knows it in Trump
yeah they've known him for 30 years and
so this didn't come as a surprise you
talked about insider so he is the
ultimate insider there's nothing you
don't know yeah no it's true it's and he
Jesse if I remember he talked about this
and about how you know there did tax
things a game I know I played the tax
game I know I've had to pay taxes I'm
pretty sure I paraphrased him first of
all I love it when you do Fox News
breaking news alerts there's so many of
them you really sell it hard I mean he
wrote a book it was the art of the
comeback and he explained every single
thing about all the tax losses you do
take a loss when you build a business I
think also in the 80s wasn't he on a
massive multi-million dollar buying
spree yes the Plaza Hotel for a half a
billion
he bought a yacht a football franchise
an airline so when you grow a business
you're gonna have some liabilities and
then you can write off with the
depreciation but the point is after he
did this and took all these losses of
the New York Times called him the
comeback King right and speaking of the
New York Times the New York Times
lost a billion dollars buying the Boston
Globe and then had to get bailed out by
Mexican billionaire Carlos Slim and they
still operate to this day on a quarter
billion dollar in losses also everybody
loses money when they're building a
business Twitter lost two billion
dollars since it went public
uber last year alone lost three billion
dollars and then let's just look at the
politicians
AOC lost this state what was it 24
billion dollars in revenue Barack Obama
doubled our debt lost a half a billion
to Solyndra lost two billion on a broken
website Hilary lost a billion her donors
shelled out when she lost the Donald
Trump so he may have lost a lot of money
but now he has towers all over the globe
he's got great golf courses and he has
the presidency pretty good what do you
think won I think he had his daddy to
bail him out I think his dad gave him
like four hundred plus million to help
him out of all his troubles is that your
types of family business but what I what
I'm struck by an in listening to all
this is you know Trump lies to his
supporters he says I'm a successful
businessman that's why I can run this
country but anyone else I'll make you
rich because I'm rich and then it turns
out it's a scam we can't race what he's
know you lost more money than anybody
else in America or where Jesse goes on
about somebody else lost money this guy
lost Mike please let's just pay
attention to the fact that the president
of the United States may in fact have
engaged in tax fraud bank fraud these
are serious consideration serious
accusations either way that's why that's
why the Congress should have access to
his tax records because if he is losing
all this money and Russia or some other
country decides oh you know what we can
get our hooks into this guy by bailing
him out we the Americans the Russians so
it's the Russian shadow diet with this
business always goes back to that you
know you talked about him talking about
being a businessman and oh you know he's
this great businessman and that was his
selling point so what's the story here
let's say he was a terrible businessman
he's not because the business is wound
up booming ultimately but even if you
say that that did not translate to a
poor economy the economy you cannot
change the reality that this guy who
went in there had experience with
business suffered some losses came out
of it still managed to get a booming
economy with his policies of
deregulation lowering taxes and whatnot
so you can't take that away from him
the truth is business owners around the
country
read a story like this I come from a
family where my mom and dad ran a small
business at two different points in
their lives it's really hard they saw
this and they saw relatability they said
yeah you know I guess what if you opened
a business whether it's small or large
new struggle you fall sometimes you're
lucky enough to be able to build
yourself back up again and he was honest
about this he said this we just played
the tape so people at home are saying
I'm sorry but what's the story here it's
not like your folks because this rich
kid had a big Daddy to come in and bail
him on and then instead of saying hey I
struggle like her he lied about it but
what here's the final point I want to
make Greg okay
socialism this is socialism for the rich
the working man in America pays taxes
and he for ten years - what paid no
taxes and we bailed she just showed me
it was broke no I pretty good doesn't
change what's going on that doesn't
change the success he's had with the
economy and voters are not voting based
on Donald Campbell record from 35 years
ago with this private business they're
voting on how much money they have in
their pocket and what life looks like
he's elected Trump coke just closed this
ice yeah they elected him over the
Democrats that's quite a cult it's like
60 some odd million in a cult you got to
start thinking if you think he's that
bad and America accepted it he's still
won because you guys suck all right